Das ist das P wie Podcast, O wie Oddcast, D wie Dcast, C wie Kast, A wie Ast, S wie St, T wie T, U wie Ufo, F wie Foh, O wie O, es geht schon los. Hey, hallo, herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Los wie, los, O wie Os, S wie Stefan, T wie Tefan, E wie Evan, F wie Fan. Das ist auch für ein Spiel. Apotheke, P-Potheke, O-Potheke, T-Potheke, H-Potheke, Epotheke, K-Potheke, Epotheke, von hinten, Epotheke, K-Potheke, Epotheke, Epotheke, O-Potheke, H-Potheke, T-Potheke, O-Potheke, P-Potheke, A-Potheke, A-Potheke. Vielen, vielen Dank für dieses tolle Intro von Annika. A wie Annika, N wie Nika, N wie Nika, I wie Ika, K wie K und A wie A. Und hi Florentin. Hallo Stefan, schön, dass du mit dabei bist, herzlich willkommen. Da sind wir wieder, das Podcast UFO. Durchatmen, einatmen, herzlich willkommen zurück, wir freuen uns, dass ihr da seid. Wir sind es wieder, Flori und Steffi im Ufo gelandet und wollen jetzt hier ein bisschen reden. Ja, wir bringen einiges mit, wir haben einiges dabei, wir haben was im Kofferraum mit dabei. Aber erst mal durchatmen, zieht die Socken aus, lasst die Zehen auch mal Zehen sein. Lasst mal jeden einzelnen Zehen mal sein eigener Zeh sein. Nicht immer nur die Fünferbande, so wie man die so sieht. Ne, nehmt mal jeden einzelnen Zeh als Individuum. Macht sie bei der Hand. Ja, als Individuum. Bei der Hand sagt ihr Daumen, ihr sagt Zeigefinger, ihr sagt Ringfinger und dann zu Zehen sagt ihr Zehen. Ja. Alle Zehen sind immer das Gleiche. Nein. Vor allem, es sind ja nicht, also man sagt ja nicht mal zwei Fünfen, man sagt ja sogar Zehen, man akzeptiert ja nicht mal diese zwei Untergruppen, sondern man haut sie alle in einen Topf, sagt Zehn und da sage ich Nein. Und der grosse, mächtige Anführer der Zehn ist der grosse Onkel. Ja. Das kenne ich. Sagt man das auch in Bayern? Nein. Der grosse Onkel? Nee, nee, nee. Grosser Onkel? Da gibt es kein Wort dafür. Es gibt kein... Das ist der Daumenzeh. Nein, man sagt nicht Daumenzeh, oder?
Man sagt nicht Daumenzeh. Es gibt keine Wörter für die Zehen, weil den Leuten die Zehen egal sind, weil man einfach sagt, mit denen habe ich sowieso keinen Kontakt, weil der Mensch riesengroß wird. Der Mensch wird ja grösser, ja, also wir kennen ja da im Museum die Ritterrüstung, wo man sagt, haben wir da Kinder gekämpft oder was? Auch. aber der hauptgrund ist dass die menschen sehr klein waren das heißt der mensch distanziert
sich immer weiter von seinen zehen läuft immer weiter weg wo verlaufen oder was auch aber der hauptgrund ist dass die menschen sehr klein waren das heißt der mensch
distanziert sich immer weiter von seinen zehen läuft immer weiter weg wo verlaufen
eigentlich davon wir bauen raketen um ganz hoch hinaus zu gehen wollen wir letzten endes nur von Ich sag dir, wir haben Angst vor Schlangen. Wir haben Angst vor Spinnen, wir haben alle Angst vor was da kreucht und fleucht unter uns, deswegen werden wir grösser, das gibt weniger Probleme, das Gift braucht länger ins Gehirn. Genau. Weil wir treten in Schlangen, wir alle treten in Schlangen und es braucht länger ins Gehirn. Genau, wir können schon unseren Fussbein abschneiden, während das Gift nach oben wandert, dann wird es schon kritisch, aber Fussbein ist alles noch Opferlich richtig, kein Problem. Hauptsache, aber eigentlich wollen wir weg von diesem Planeten, weg zu einem Planeten, wo es keine Spinnen und Schlangen gibt. Ja, das ist glaube ich wichtig, dass da so eine Urangst in uns drin ist. Ich meine, du bist ein sehr grosser Mensch. Du hast ja eigentlich einen guten, eingebauten Schutz gegen alles kreuchende, fleuchende Aussage, springt dir direkt ins Gesicht. Es gibt wirklich ja die Theorie, dass Menschen, die schon sehr früh sehr gross sind, so ein bisschen weird, zu weirdness neigen, nämlich im eigenen Kopf zu sein. Dafür gibt es ein Wort, das habe ich wie immer nicht parat, weil ich nicht nach. Vielleicht, wahrscheinlich nicht, weil ich nicht daran denke, aber... Weil es für dich natürlich ist. Der Fisch hat auch kein Wort für Wasser. Es macht der Sinn. Der Mensch hat kein Wort für Luft. Es ist so selbstverständlich, es gibt kein Wörter dafür. Aber es gibt nicht immer ein Wort dafür. Ja, genau. Ne, ich meine nur, es ergibt ja auf eine Art Sinn, wenn man sehr früh sozusagen den Kontakt zu seinen Gliedmassen verliert und auch merkt, alle anderen sind anders, ich bin anders, sich jetzt alienhaft wahrzunehmen, führt schnell zu einer frühkindlichen Entkopplung zwischen Körper und Geist. Ja, ja. Etwas, was wir beide ein bisschen haben, glaube ich, als die neurotischen Persönlichen, die wir sind, glaube ich schon, dass es eine gewisse Entkopplung zwischen Körper und Geist gibt und wir den Körper eher als nerviges Anhängsel betrachten, als als wichtigen Bestandteil, mit dem es sich zu leben lohnt, als als Tempel, was so diese ganzen, so diese Nahrungsergänzungsmittel Gymbros, die, glaube ich, ein anderes Vernis im körper haben als wir ja oder nehmen dies nicht eher als gefängnis war und wollen sich ihr gefängnis nur schön einrichten auch eine möglichkeit ich habe aber auch gehört dass es die theorie gibt dass schlangen sich aneinander knoten um eine unbesiegbare riesen schlange zu werden die dann viereinhalb Kilometer lang ist die eigentlich unaufhalam ist, die angeführt von der stärksten Schlange und das und dem grössten dem grossen Onkel.
So genau, aber das Ding ist, Stefan denkt jetzt, ah Moment, er meint wohl, dass sich alle Nattern verknoten. Stopp, habe ich nicht gesagt. Du meinst speziesübergreifend?
Spezienübergreifende Schlangenknoten.
Alle Schlangen zusammen.
Da hängt eine Natter an der Otter, da hängt eine Otter
an einer Viper, da hängt eine Viper
an einer Boa Constricta, da hängt
eine Boa Constricta an einer Cobra.
Ja, alles durchgemischt.
Wir haben ja eine Schlange, die nicht auf E, R oder A endet.
Die Klapperschlange. Oh, Klapper!
Ja, aber du willst nicht
hinter der Klapperschlange zugeteilt werden.
Weil sonst hängst du an der Klapperschlange und die klappert dir ganz viel. Hat diese Riesenschlange nicht trotzdem nur einen Mund? Äh, ja. Das heißt, du hast eine eine... Können Sie mir vielleicht ihre Sassy-Stimmung mal erklären, Herr Student? Äh, ne, ich wollte sagen, weil die tolle Idee, die Sie gerade vorstellen, am Ende hat es einen kleinen Mund, ne?
Ja, und? Ja, zwei Giftzähne, ne? Selbst diese Riesenschlange, erst mal ist sie super unkoordiniert, viel zu gross, es dauert ewig, bis hinten ankommt, wo die Schlange hin will, und dann hast du trotzdem nur noch zwei Zähne, also warum ist sie so geil? weil sie so lange ist, vielleicht?
Troll, ey.
Schaut euch den an.
Schaut euch den an. Schaut euch den an. Ihr wollt nicht an den geknotet sein. Stellt euch vor, ihr seid die Schlange, die an den Typen geknotet ist, in der langen Schlange. Warum sind sie so gemein, Herr Professor? Sie sind unwissenschaftlich und gemein. Du hast zuerst, Herr C. Ja, weil die Idee so bescheuert ist. Ich beschreibe die Realität, wie sie ist, nicht wie ich sie mir wünsche. Das hab, als ich in Borneo war, hab ich das gesehen, wie mehrere Schlangen hintereinander geknotet durch den Dschungel gerobbt sind. War das nicht eher, weil die, also glauben sie, dass Delfine, die in Netzen sind, dass sie sich festschneiden? Es ist bekannt, dass Delfine sich gemeinsam in ein Netz werfen, um einen Superdelfin zu bauen. Und mit diesem Superdelfin, haben Sie mal die Power Rangers gesehen? Sie haben nicht mal die Grundlagenliteratur gelesen. Sie kommen hier in eine Vorlesung und denken, Sie könnten mir hier freche Fragen stellen, wenn Sie doch nicht mal Power Rangers Zero gesehen haben, wo schon in Folge drei ein Megasort beschworen wird, wo sich alle Power Ranger vereinen. Okay, lesen Sie erstmal die Grundlagen. Glauben Sie, wenn ein Adler auf eine Ratte stürzt und die greift, dass die ein Rattenadler Riesenmonster ist? Der so genannte Radler. Die Ratte kontrolliert den Adler, ist eine Symbiose. Nein, Radler ist Spreit mit Bier. Äh, nein. Das Sassy-Schüler-Konsortium. Ein Riesen-Konsortium. Neues Wort gelernt. Ein komplettes Konsortium. Ich habe ein komplett neues Wort gelernt. Also, ich habe ja echt nicht vor vielen Dingen Angst. Ich würde es mir so ungern mit einem Konsortium anlegen. Ey, wenn ich wirklich höre Schlagzeile, Konsortium ist hinter Florentin Wilherr, nee, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf. Okay, Gewerkschaft? Wirklich jemand sagt, Gewerkschaft kein Problem. Konsortium? Konglomerat, überhaupt kein Problem. Konglomerat ist kein Problem, die sind viel zu unorganisiert. Die hängen gar nicht dicht beieinander. Konsortium sind Strukturen. Da gibt es gewachsene Strukturen, wohl überlegte, über mehrere Generationen gewachsene Strukturen.
Und auch zweckgebundene Strukturen, die arbeiten auf ein Ziel hin.
Das ist nicht irgendwie so ein Verein, der da so vor sich hingurkt.
Ein Konsortium hat ein Ziel vor Ort.
Anti-Will-Konsortium macht mir Angst, wenn man es alleine ausspricht.
Da hätte ich Probleme, da würde ich ausreisen.
Und im letzten Endes sind nicht viele Schlangen, die sich zusammenknoten, nicht auch nur ein Schlangenkonsortium. Oder wenn es die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist, die Welt ist ausspricht. Da hätte ich Probleme, da würde ich ausreisen. Und im letzten Ende sind nicht viele Schlangen, die sich zusammenknoten, nicht auch nur ein Schlangenkonsortium. Oder soll ich etwas sagen, konssortium, sortio. Ich finde, ich habe keine Angst vor zusammenknotenden Schlangen. Nee? Nee. Ich würde dann das Ende nehmen und dann würde ich ganz schnell zum Anfang laufen und dann würde ich zusammen. Ja, ein riesen ring und er kriecht im kreis bis ihm ganz schwindelig wird stopp leute stopp leute ich muss anhalten stopp leute jetzt bin völlig schwindelig warum wird uns schwindelig jetzt halt die klappe seit stunden nervst du mich mit deinen fragen ich wollte mich nicht an dich knoten aber ich wurde dir zugewiesen. Und warum haben wir uns Kopf an Knopf geknotet? Das war von Anfang an eine Scheissidee. Ich würde ja dein Arsch sein. Ja, aber das kommen wir ja nicht voran. Ich will nicht, ich weiß nicht genau, wo dein Arsch ist. Ich weiß, wo ist unser Arsch. Arschloch. Ich hab, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich hab mich komplett von meinen Füssen distanziert. Ja, war ich nicht mehr. Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich Füsse hab. Ich habe schon so lange nicht mehr unter. Ich halte das hier für eine scheisse Idee. Ich kriege weg, sobald jemand einschläft, da vorne. Sobald da jemand einschläft, bin ich weg. Ja, aber dann verlieren, dann hängen ja alle an dir dran. Dann sind es ja zwei Riesenschlangen. Dann bin ich der Anfang der Polonaise. Ja, jeder, der aussteigt. Du willst nicht der Anfang, warst du mal, ernsthafte Frage, warst du mal der Anfang einer Polonaise? Ja, jeder der aussteigt. Warst du mal, ernsthafte Frage, warst du mal der Anfang einer Polonaise? Nein. Ich war schon mal der Anfang einer Polonaise. Aber wie funktioniert das? Hast du dich abgekapselt? Hast du dich abgekapselt oder Anschluss verloren? Gib's zu. Hast du Anschluss verloren oder dich aktiv gesagt, nein, stopp, wir gehen einen anderen Weg. Ich habe mich aus Versehen abgekapselt, also Anschluss verloren. Ah, okay. Nee, aber es ist ja viel besser als derjenige, du willst ja nicht derjenige sein, der, erst mal, wie entstehen diese Konstrukte, das ist mir ja auch schon ein Rätsel, weil du machst, du nimmst ja dann einen Kumpel und sagst, komm, fass mich an, hier hinten, also ist das super weird, dieser initiale Moment. Eigentlich muss ja dich jemand zum Anführer machen, jemand legt seine Hände auf deine Schulter und sagt voran. Aber dann muss er direkt in dem Mode sein. Mein Käpt'n, mein Käpt'n und du gehst voran. Mit dem Arme hoch Mode und dann tanzend, Schrohut und zack gehst du da vorne. Ich hätte Angst vor der Verantwortung, weil ich glaube, ich würde den klassischen Snake-Fehler machen. Ich würde drei Linkskurven machen, um dann dem Körper der Schlange wieder direkt in die Seite zu gehen, dann hätte ich verloren. Und dann würde ich da einfach reinrauschen, ohne halten zu können, weil der Druck hinter mir zu gross ist und dann gäbe es eine grosse Karambolage, eine Polonesen-Karambolage. Ich bin ehrlich, ich habe nicht so eine wahnsinnige Polonesen-Erfahrung. Okay, das finde ich aber gut, dass du das mal öffentlich sagst, dass du einfach noch nicht so viel Erfahrung gesammeltelt hast. Es ist ja auch kein Wettrennen. Es geht ja auch nicht darum, du bist jetzt Anfang 30, aber das ist ja völlig in Ordnung, dass du sagst, dass du noch nicht so viel Polonesen-Erfahrung gesammelt hast. Ne, ich bin nicht, aber trotzdem fühle ich mich hier jetzt irgendwie wohl genug, um euch allen zu sagen, ich habe nicht so viel Polonaisenerfahrung.
Das finde ich super.
Und ich finde, da kann man einfach auch offen mal jetzt drüber sprechen. Wenn ich vorne stehe, habe ich einfach ... Hey, ist okay, lass raus. Lass raus. Ich habe einfach die Angst, dass ich nicht genau weiss, wohin. Soll ich dir die Hände auf die Schultern legen, für Unterstützung? Nein, bitte nicht. Um Gottes willen nein. Okay, um Gottes willen nein. Um Gottes willen nein. Das war eine dumme Idee. Okay, tut mir leid, das war eine dumme Idee. sorry. Bitte. Ich weiß nicht, ob nach rechts oder links oder geradeaus oder schräg rechts oder schräg links. Man hat so viele Auswahlmöglichkeiten. Man hat so viele Auswahlmöglichkeiten. Man will nicht zu schnell den Bogen machen, weil man hat doch einen grösseren Raum, aus dem man schöpfen kann. Muss ich aber, will ich ganz in die Ecke gehen? Nein, nicht in die Ecke. Ist es meine Aufgabe, Leute einzusammeln, damit die Polonese immer grösser wird? Nee, das geht ja gar nicht. Die können sich ja gar nicht an die Dichter anhängen.
Aber verstehst du diese ganzen Fragen, wie sie sich auftun, wo lang, wie ist, was machen die Arme?
Aber weisst du, das kommt ganz natürlich. Wenn du da mal drin bist, dann weisst du schon, was zu tun ist.
Du darfst einfach nur keine Angst haben, da einzusteigen.
So, ich frage jetzt, wie natürlicherweise Polonaise entstehen.
Wir gehen los mit ganz grossen Schritten.
Weil ich will nicht wissen, ich habe noch nie
gesehen, ähnlich wie ich noch nie Jogger
gesehen habe, wie sie anfangen zu joggen,
oder Tauben als Babys,
habe ich auch noch nie gesehen,
wie Polonesen starben.
Ja, sie tauchen plötzlich auf.
Als wären sie für immer da, sozusagen. War die die ganze Zeit schon da, diese Polonaise. Ein Konsortium hat sich ergeben. Also, Polonesen auf Partys entstehen oft spontan und sind ein Ausdruck kollektiver Ausgelassenheit und Gemeinschaftsgefühl. Der Prozess, wie solche spontan Polonesen natürlich entstehen, kann durch verschiedene soziale und psychologische Faktoren erklärt werden. This guy sounds like fun, man. Es müssen mindestens vier dieser neun Grundbedingungen gegeben sein, damit eine Polonaise entstehen kann. Dichte, es muss mindestens pro Quadratmeter 0,5 Personen anwesend sein. Ey Felix, du hast doch gesagt, ich kann jemanden mitnehmen zur Party, ne? Ja klar, bring mit, egal was. Du meinst, ich kann jeden mitnehmen. Je mehr, desto besser, das wird die geilste Party des Jahres, Mann, okay? Genau, das ist Henrik und das ist ein mega cooler Kumpel von mir. Ich gehe kurz zur Bar, also das ist Henrik, ne? Henrik, Felix, Felix, Henrik. Oh, hi Henrik, was geht alles, alles gut? Oh, dort hinten ist eine Polonaise. Polonesen auf Partys entstehen oft spontan und sind ein Ausdruck kollektiver Ausgelassenheit.
Okay, alles klar, nimm dir ein Bier, Henrik, was geht.
Und Gemeinschaftsgefühl.
Okay, ja, lass uns teilnehmen.
Der Prozess, wie solche spontan und Polonesen natürlich entstehen, kann durch verschiedene soziale und psychologische Faktoren erklärt werden.
Ja man, lass loslegen, lass Spaß haben. Okay. Äääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääää. Und das ist oft der Auslöser für eine solche Polonaise. Bestimmte Lieder mit einem erkennbaren Rhythmus oder einer Melodie, die viele Menschen mit Tanz oder Bewegung assoziieren, können die Initialzündung sein. Mit einer Melodie, die Leute mit Tanz assoziieren. Wie soll das denn funktionieren? Wie Macarena, wie He Macarena. He Macarena. Soziale Anstärkung, Menschen neigen dazu, das Verhalten anderer in ihrer Umgebung zu imitieren, besonders in sozialen Situationen. Aber eigentlich müsste man den Mut haben, wenn eine Polonaise entsteht, sofort eine Konterpolonaise zu starten und sofort den Konflikt zu suchen und den Kampf heraufzubeschwören, so dass jeder Partei ergreifen muss und am Ende die gesamte Party sich in zwei langen Schlangen auflöst, die natürlich am Ende gegeneinander antreten werden und sich wirklich wie in einem Schlangenkampf in sich verknoten.
Das ist meine Anzeige. Im Zweifelsfall ordnet sich die schwächere Schlange der grössere Brunten. Jedes Thema, wenn es so zwangslei auf dieser Zusammenknoten scheinbar funktioniert, aber man kann wirklich viel mit Menschen machen. Neulich habe ich auch so ein Video gesehen von so einem sozialen Social Pressure Versuchsaufbau.
Und zwar ist so ein Kreis aus, irgendwie so eine Stuh mit so zehn Stühlen. Und es sitzen schon drei da, das sind Schauspieler. Also Schal und auch ein bisschen arrogant. So ein Overall. Das sind Meryl Streep, Jude Law und Matthias Schweighäfer. Und hinten sitzt jemand versteckt im Nebenraum, der hat so eine Glocke, diese Halligalliglocke, dieses Pling. Und immer wenn er drauf drückt, stehen sie auf und wenn es wiederkommt, setzen sie sich hin. Das ist unregelmässig. Und dann kommt irgendwann der erste normale Mensch rein und denen wird gesagt, ihr seid bei einer Audition für irgendeine Rolle. Und es kommt der erste Mensch rein, der setzt sich natürlich hin. Und dann kommt dieses Pling und die drei stehen auf. Und derjenige ist super irritiert und will aber nicht auffallen als jemand, der nicht verstanden hat, worum es hier gerade geht, weiss aber nicht, worum es geht, gibt es auch nicht zu verstehen, trotzdem steht er auch auf. Bis dann, weil der nächste reinkam, der nächste reinkam und die Idee war, sobald jemand sich wehrt, und dann kam wirklich eine rein, die hat sich nicht daran beteiligt, die hat einfach so einen Zettel ausgefüllt und sitzen geblieben immer, obwohl alle anderen stehen und sich hinsetzen, und sie wurde dann abgeführt.
Da kamen die Leute rein und haben gesagt, du musst jetzt rausgehen. Und sie so, okay, ist rausgegangen. Dann kamen neue Leute rein, die immer konform blieben. Und dann am Ende war dann der Gag, also die Pointe des ganzen Aufbaus und was es aussagen soll, die drei Ersten, die Schauspieler, sind gegangen. Und dann hat hinten jemand wieder Pling gemacht und der Rest ist aufgestanden und sich hingesetzt. Und wusste gar nicht, warum. Und niemand von denen, also niemand hat gesagt, stellt euch hin oder setzt euch hin bei diesem Geräusch. Weil initial ist niemand mehr dabei jetzt, der den Anfang mitbekommen hat. Das heißt, und so funktionieren Polonesen auch auf eine Art. Man sieht nicht, wie sie beginnen, sie sind einfach da. Man reiht sich ein, irgendwann gehen die Ersten weg und man steckt noch drin in diesem Lauf. Und sind wir nicht die Leute, die am Ende dazukommen? Obwohl, ich muss sagen, wenn Meryl Streep aufstehen würde, würde ich auch einfach aufstehen und würde sagen, okay, pass auf, ich bin neu in der Gruppe, Meryl Streep, Matthias Schweighöfer, ich bin von einem Fan, vom anderen nicht so. Jude Law möchtest du ignorieren? Jude Law würde ich erstmal ignorieren, aber ich finde, Jude Law ist auch so der nahbarste, wo ich sagen kann, ey, wo ich sage, hey Jude, don't let me down, wohingegen bei den anderen beiden würde ich sagen, okay, wenn die aufstehen, muss ich schon auch mit aufstehen. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht das Experiment ein bisschen verfälscht hat, dass du halt wirklich A-List Hollywood Actor genommen hast, die da irgendwie, warum sind die überhaupt, also warum machen die da mit Nehmen die jede Rolle an oder was? Also ist es... Ich meine, Meryl Streep könnte alles spielen. Die könnte sogar selber einen Film drehen. Die könnte ein Skript schreiben, ein Drehbuch und selber Regie führen. Kein Problem. Die kann ihre eigenen Ideen umsetzen. Trotzdem nimmt sie die Rolle an von so einer, wo war das, Hannover? So einer Hannover-Universität. Trotzdem ist sie in jedem Drecks-TikTok, was ich sehe, spielt Meryl Streep die Hauptrolle. Bei jedem Strassenprank, wo irgendwie jemandem der Hotdog runterfällt oder sowas, spielt Meryl Streep mit. Das Hotdog. Manchmal sogar das Hotdog. Aber ich finde es so geil und ich habe mir vorgestellt, bin ich nicht und du auch nicht, sind wir nicht im Lauf des Lebens die Menschen, die zu siebt, acht dahingesetzt werden und machen wir nicht alles so, wie uns vorgelebt wird, sollten wir nicht sitzen bleiben. Oder aufstehen. Ja, okay, je nachdem. Ja, je nachdem. Wenn ihr sitzt, solltet ihr nicht aufstehen. Oder wenn ihr aufsteht, solltet ihr euch nicht hinsetzen? Aber da machen wir immer noch alles konform, wir machen nur das Gegenteil. Ähm, jetzt pass auf. Drehen, wir können uns drehen.
Okay, das hier ist Kirsten Dunst.
Die bewirbt sich hier auch gerade auf eine Stelle.
Okay?
Ist krass, was wir jetzt, wenn die A-Listers bekommen.
Und, ähm, oh, ist das Peter Dinklage?
Der möchte sich hier auch, der möchte sich auch bewerben für diesen Werbespot.
Okay.
Also setzt euch ein ... oder ...
Ah!
Bläh!
Egal.
Reset, reset, reset, reset.
Ich bin dumm, ich bin dumm, ich bin dumm, ich bin dumm, ich bin dumm, okay.
So.
Macht was ihr wollt.
Ich kann mich nicht vor Meryl Streep versprechen.
Ich darf mich nicht vor Meryl Streep versprechen.
Hi, Meryl, setzt sich doch einfach schon mal hin.
Setz sich doch einfach schon mal hin. Rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr doch einfach schon mal hin. The goat, the goat, the goat, die beste, Schauspiel, Streep, Meryl, Meryl. Wäre nicht aber auch witzig, so eine Doku über ein Experiment, wo einfach die unfähigsten Leute dieses Experiment leiten. Einfach die schon sagen, wo die sich verplappern, so ihr seid ja hier wegen dem psychologischen Test, äh, wegen der, äh, genau, wegen der Bewerbung für den Werbespot, wo ihr, und, ähm, genau, ähm, die Glocke, soll ich das mit der Glocke sehen, äh, nee, guckt einfach, was, was passiert und, ähm, seid gespannt, macht gleich das, was die Ersten machen, auch oder nicht, oder? Egal, euch drei kenne ich ja gar nicht, äh, wie, Name nochmal, Zwinker, Zwinker, warum zwinkern sie sie an? Äh, hä? Warum zwinkern sie sie an? Weil ich sie nicht kenne, weil ich sie nicht kenne. Sie halten den Versuchsaufbau falsch herum, wir können sehen. Oh, oh, oh, Entschuldigungschuldigung tschuldigung so war von euch jemand schon mal bei einem psychologischen bei einem bewerbungs okay alles klar ist das hier ein psychologischer Test nein nein sie dürfen nicht lügen sind wie Cops wenn man die fragt sind sie sind sie ein Polizist müssen sie die Wahrheit sagen es gibt er sagt immer die Wahrheit und ich lüge immer okay und ihr müsst rausfinden wer lügt und Sie die Wahrheit sagen. Es gibt, er sagt immer die Wahrheit und ich lüge immer. Okay. Und ihr müsst rausfinden, wer lügt und wer die Wahrheit sagt. Wer von euch würde auf die Frage mit Ja beantworten, wenn ich frage, ist das hier ein psychologischer Test? Nicht ich. Beide, beide. Oh, das wäre gelo... Ah, okay.
Wie so eine Arte-Doku und der Zuschauer so, was, was betroffen.
Und das Unglaubliche ist dann erst noch passiert.
Die Probanden haben sich geweigert, aufzustehen, weil sie laut gesagt haben, ja, ist das jetzt der Test oder was?
Ja, haben wir bestanden oder verloren?
Hallo, hallo, hallo, schau direkt in die Kamera. Ah, das fände ich auch schon mal gut. Zwickert rein. Aber wo du sagst, so ein Trottel, der diesen Versuchsaufbau macht. Ich habe mir neulich gedacht, weil man spricht ja sozusagen von unserem technologischen Fortschritt. Wir haben 2024 den und den technologischen Fortschritt und so weit sind wir als Menschheit. Und man betrachtet das immer so als keine Ahnung, so weit sind wir, so weit sind unsere Handys, wir können zum Mars fliegen, whatever. Aber man betrachtet das nicht so richtig individuell. Man denkt nicht, ah, darin sind wir schon sehr, sehr gut. Also ich hätte gerne so eine, so eine Aussenperspektive von so einer Alien-Zivilisation, die irgendwie uns in Petri-Dish anguckt und sagt, ah krass, wie gut sie darin sind für ihre Verhältnisse, für ihr Entwicklungsstadium. Und was glaubst du, weil ich habe das Gefühl, wir, was so, was so, wenn man technologisch bleibt, bei Laptops oder Handys oder sowas, ich finde, grafisch sind wir sehr, sehr weit. Ja, aber das hat man bei der Playstation 1 auch schon gesagt. Bei der Playstation 1 haben auch alle gesagt, das ist fotorealistisch, und heute sind es halt flackernde Pics oder so. War es ja nicht, aber jetzt ist es das ja. So, aber ich denke mir, Batterien sind wir sehr, sehr schlecht. Weißt du was? Wir haben super schlechte Batterien. Ja, aber können nicht die Aliens sagen, holy shit, what the fuck, sieben Stunden Laufzeit? Wir haben acht. Alter, ihr seid fast fast im Endgame. Oder können wir nur sehr gut Ferngläser bauen zu dieser... Ja, das kann auch sein. Also vielleicht bauen wir einfach nur ... Nee, ich meine das, ey, P7. Ich meine das ernst. Ja, ja, ich weiß schon. P7, du hörst mir nicht zu. Klar. Ich glaube, wir bauen einfach nur sehr, sehr gut Ferngläser. Wenn uns jemand angucken würde, würden die sagen, ah krass, die bauen sehr, sehr schlechte Batterien, die haben nur acht Stunden, dafür können sich andere Zivilisationen mit dem Teleskop angucken. Ja. Das kann auch sein. Ich weiß auch nicht. Ich habe das Gefühl, bei uns ist es wirklich, also Batterien sind sehr, sehr schlecht bei uns. Ja. Sehr, sehr schlecht. Dann sowas wie Bluetooth ist auch unglaublich schlecht. Ja, super schlecht. Also diese Verbindungen zwischen zwei Geräten. Aber wir wissen ja nicht, ob es schon maximal gut ist oder ob wir einfach nur stümperhaft sind. Es kann ja sein, dass die Aliens kommen und sagen, Alter, Schiffe habt ihr komplett durchgezockt. Ihr bekommt sehr schnelle Schiffe. Schiffe sind einfach perfekt. Echt? Schiffe? 19 Knoten. Hält ich jetzt knapp? Ja, 19, 20 vielleicht gerade noch mit irgendwie, wir haben einen Fusionsreaktor, kriegst vielleicht gerade noch so 20 hin bei einem sonnigen Tag ohne Wellengang, ja. Aber ansonsten seid ihr da echt gut, also Respekt. Respekt, Respekt. Wir haben ja auch was Besonderes, wir haben dieses Akku von unserem Handy. Was? Hä? Was? Sieben Stunden? Nee, das ist ja. Aber ich nehme mir so vor, dass dann so Departments fliegen. Okay, das wir nochmal aussortieren. Ja, ja, genau. Weil ich habe das Gefühl, so diese ganze Bluetooth-Technologie, diese ohne Kabel oder sowas, Datentransfer-Shit, ohne Berührung, ohne Kontakt, da hat die Menschheit als Abteilung versagt. Batterien hat die Menschheit als Abteilung versagt. Ja, oder ich meine auch körperlich. Also ich meine, so der Weltrekord im 100-Meter-Sprint wird ja auch immer wieder gebrochen, also man wird ja immer schneller im Laufe der Zeit. Genau. Und die Alien-Raste sagt Sprinten, boah, da ist ja der ganz hinten. Aber Snooker, da seid ihr im Universum die Besten. Ja, ich will. Und du denkst so, ernsthaft, da sind wir die Besten? Ja. Guck mal, ich denke mir bei Baseball, die laufen nicht schnell, die sprinten nicht wirklich. Nee, die haben einen Hotdog in Hand teilweise. Aber kann man das nicht herausfinden, was objektiv der beste Sport ist? Kann man das nicht herausfinden? Es sind Leute, die spielen geteilt durch ... Nein, nein, nein, Sprints zum Beispiel. Also du kannst herausfinden, zum Beispiel Basketball, Baseball und Fußball. Und vielleicht noch, könntest du herausfinden, wer trainiert, wer sprintet am schnellsten. Die kurzen Sprints kannst du ja sozusagen mit Kameras messen, wie schnell die sind. Dann siehst du ja schon mal, welche dieser, obwohl es sind alle Sportarten, wo Sprints, ja gut, Basketball können wir vielleicht auch rauskegeln, aber so Sportarten, wo so kurze Sprints kegeln rein, Bowling rein, Kegelsportarten rein. Ja, ja. Neearten rein ja ja ne verstehst du was ich meine ich verstehe schon es ist natürlich schwer zu vergleichen weil du natürlich auch andere körperbauten brauchst wenn du jetzt irgendwie football und da musst du halt krass den weg blocken können dann kannst du vielleicht nicht mehr so schnell rennen aber die haben ja auch den werfer und den receiver der receiver muss doch genau so schnell rennen können wie sozusagen so ein aussenverteidiger im Fußball. Und dann nehmen wir auch gleich Körperbau. Dann können beide Sprinten nicht sehen, ist da in der Premier League oder in der NFL sind da die besten Sprints. Das Problem ist halt auch, dass nur weil du viel trainierst, das nicht heisst, dass du der Beste bist. Ich habe zum Beispiel, ein Freund von mir ist Musiker und er spielt Klavier und ich dachte mal, so in so einem Bonding-Moment dachte ich mir so, hier, guck dir mal die Perkussionisten an, so mit ihren Trommeln, oder? Die sind schon richtig schlecht und dumm. Da dachte ich, bei meiner Art mit einem Musiker, dachte ich, okay, gemeinsamer Feind. Und er meinte, nee, das ist unfassbar anspruchsvoll. Und wir waren im Orchestercamp und die haben mit Abstand am längsten geübt. Die waren immer... Ja, vielleicht waren die nur sehr schlecht am Anfang. Wirklich, die Trommler, die irgendwie einmal pro Symphonie so ein... Ja. Und dann legen sie sich wieder hin. Dafür müssen die so viel trainieren, wo ich mir dachte, okay, anscheinend... Aber da habe ich überhaupt keine Ahnung, wie man mit Leuten redet, Punkt eins, Punkt zwei, ist es für Außenstehende schwer zu verstehen, was wirklich anspruchsvoll ist und was nicht und was viel Übung erfordert und was nicht. Genau. Und seitdem habe ich einfach noch weniger Respekt vor Perkussionisten, weil wenn ich mir das angucke und weiß, die haben dafür ganz lange trainiert, habe ich noch weniger Respekt vor ihnen. Wenn die sagen, ach so, ich habe vor einer Stunde einen Klöppel in jemals das erste Mal in der Hand gehabt,
kein Problem, dann würde ich sagen, okay, das ist krass.
Aber deswegen, und deswegen,
sorry, aber ich habe wenig Respekt vor Percusinist.
Warum? Weil sich plump vorkommt als ... Ja, weil es für mich, also,
ich respektiere natürlich alle als Teil des Orchesters, ist klar.
Klingt nicht so. Aber ich habe mir noch nie gedacht,
oh, ich wäre gern der an der Trommel.
Doch, voll, natürlich. Wirklich?
Mach richtig Lärm.
Du machst richtig Lärm.
Ja, Lärm.
Du sagst es ja selber, Lärm.
Ist schon, hat schon was.
Ich glaube, es ist auch anspruchsvoll, weil du halt sehr, du musst am konzentriertesten sein.
Weil du halt wirklich, erst mal fällst du auf, Wahnsinn, du bist auch nicht keine Sektion, sondern du bist ein Einzeltyp.
Und dann musst du halt wirklich die ganze Zeit Takt zählen, Takt zählen, Takt zählen.
Ja, aber da meine ich nur, dass es jetzt bei dir vielleicht so ist, dass manche Sportarten vielleicht stümperhaft wirken wie Baseball, wo du jetzt als Aussenstehender sagst, die haben irgendwie die Tüle Rosinen in der Hand, wenn sie auf den Ball warten und so, das ist lame. Aber du kannst es vielleicht noch nicht einschätzen und das sind eigentlich die härtesten, die krassesten Athleten, die am meisten Arbeit reinstecken, aber es überträgt sich halt nur. Deswegen, mir geht es gar nicht darum, bei welchem Sport sind wir die besten, sondern eher darum, bei welchem Sport kann ich am besten aussehen mit wenigsten Investitionen. Ich will möglichst kompetent wirken, so diese klassischen drei Akkorde auf der Gitarre, wo du sagst, das kannst du in fünf Minuten lernen und alle denken, alter, okay, krass, du kannst Gitarre spielen.ass, da können alle Green Day Songs spielen. Genau, was ist da das Equivalent, wo man sagt, okay, du lernst einmal einen Fallrückzieher und kannst dann eigentlich immer dominieren. Ja, oder Wirtschaft, also sagen wir mal, irgendwelche Jobs. Bei welchem Job kannst du am ehesten was leisten, ohne dich mega gut auszukennen, wenn wir nochmal die Aliens heranziehen? Ja, ich hab... Welchem Job kann ich am ehesten die Welt nachhaltig verändern,
weil wir einfach fucking schlecht sind mit XY?
Es gibt ja so eine YouTube-Reihe, wo verschiedene Berufe vorgestellt werden
und die auch ganz transparent sagen, was die verdienen.
Galileo.
Nee, wo die ganz transparent sagen, was die verdienen.
Irgendwie so, lohnt sich das, wird das was, kann ich das, sowas. Irgend irgendwie so eine Doku-Reihe. Mit Mary Streep. Genau, Mary Streep ist mit dabei. Und da war letztens ein Beruf vorgestellt, Legionellen-Tester. Der testet Legionellen, also Legionellen sind so Bakterien, die in Wasserleitungen drin sein können, und der fährt dann in eine Wohnung, nimmt einen Schluck Wasser und sagt, ja, passt. Teste dann diese Wassersorten. Mit Geschmack? Nein, nicht mit Geschmack, sondern mit Labor. Ja, wenn du so eine super special ingest. Ja, aber mein Gott. Aber ich muss es, der Beruf ist so langweilig, dass ich selbst in der Erklärung das Gefühl hatte, ich muss dir was ausdenken, weil es so langweilig ist. Und dann stand da so, wie viel die verdienen, und die verdienen nicht schlecht. Also da sitzt kein schlechter verdienst. Und dann hieß es ja, Ausbildung muss man auch mal, wie lange muss man Ausbildung machen und so, Ausbildung ein Tag. Und dann dachte ich mir, das ist der beste Job der Welt.
Du bist der Legionellenmann, fährst von Wohnung zu Wohnung, nimmst Wasserproben.
Legionellenmänner, halt!
Legionellenmänner, Tester nach vorne!
Präsentiert euer Wasser!
Okay, ihr seid durch! Bravo! Legionit der, ich bin stolz auf euch!
Und dann so eine dreistündige Rede.
Weil wisst ihr noch, als wir heute morgen hier standen und dachten, wie machen sie das, und ihr zu euren Helden geguckt, ihr habt, ich hab euch Bernhard Sprengler vorgestellt, den grössten aller legionellen Tester und ihr habt da mit Tränen in den Augen gestanden gesagt, so einer will nicht mal werden. Jetzt ist der Moment gekommen. Nach harten acht Stunden, gut wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde Mittagspause gemacht, aber nach harten acht Stunden Arbeit habt ihr es endlich geschafft, ihr seid legionellen Tester, ihr seid geprüfte und staatlich anerkannte legionellen Tester. Oh, scheiße, ich bin zu spät gekommen. Ah, ich dachte, wir klopfen gemeinsam. Ich bin zu spät gekommen, sorry. Es ist beim allgemeinen Klopfen untergegangen, dass du an der Tür geklopft hast. Deswegen hat mir jemand aufgemacht. Sorry, ich bin zu spät gekommen. Krieg ich auch noch einen Schein? Ja, komm, okay. Also ist eh alles scheißegal. Ist eh alles scheißegal. Legionellen, bei uns ist doch eh alles scheiss egal. Aber das stimmt nicht. Nee, das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Legionellen sind eine Riesengefahr. Die lauern, die haben ihre Hunderte, also die haben Heerschaden zur Verfügung. An Füsschen. An kleinen Füsschen. An kleine gemeine Füsschen. Wir haben Angst vor Schlangen, dabei hätten wir eigentlich lieber Angst haben sollen vor den kleinsten Dingen, die wir nämlich nicht mit bloßem Auge sehen.
Richtig. Aber was wir nicht sehen können, haben wir keine Angst vor.
Wie viele Schlangen sind im Abwasser, frag ich. Wie viele Schlangen fliessen gerade durch unser Wassersystem?
Legionellen bringen nicht langsam um oder schnell, eins und beide, niemals bringen die sich um, wir wissen nicht genau, wie sie funktioniert, aber Legionellen sind gefährlich.
Und deswegen habe ich euch schon mal gesagt, wenn ihr nach Hause kommt aus dem Urlaub, macht alle Wasserhine auf. Alle Wasserhine aufmachen, alle schaut mal auf. Und dann wird zu. Okay. Und weil das ist wichtig, um die Legionellen rauszuspülen. Den Mittelstrahl will man immer. Bitte? Den Mittelstrahl. Man will nicht den Anfang, sondern man will mittig in den Strahl. Ja, oder das Ende. Ende ist auch okay. Auch okay. Ende ist auch okay. Anfang nicht gut, da bilden sich Legionellen. Aber okay, das ist nämlich die gute Frage, weil wenn man jetzt mal geht nach so klassisch Nutzrechnung. Man will ein gutes Leben, man braucht leider in der Gesellschaft, in der wir sind, sehr viel Geld, bedeutet auch ein besseres Leben. Hier, Zaster. Und mehr Zeit ist auch gleich besseres Leben. Was ist der beste Job für den Bruch am wenigsten Ausbildungszeit und kann direkt ein gutes Gehalt bekommen, um dann maximal viel Freizeit zu haben und wenig Stress auf der Arbeit? Ich sag ja immer Zoll. Ich sag den Leuten immer Zoll, aber jetzt sag ich, ich hab bisher immer Zoll gesagt, ab jetzt sag ich Legionellentester. Weißt du, es ist immer so, mir schreiben dann auch Leute so, ja, ich bin jetzt fertig mit dem Abi, ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll und so, und dann sag ich immer, geh zum Zoll. Wo auch die Leute sagen, nee, lass mal. Schreibt nicht, mein Tipp ist, schreibt nicht Florentin, der, weil du bist nie mit einem Plan durch, also im besten Sinne, du bist nicht mit einem Plan durchs Leben gegangen. Aber deswegen sage ich ab jetzt immer, ich bin gerade aus der Schule raus, ich habe mein 3,8 Abi. Was soll ich machen? Ihr schreibt Abitur am Dienstag und am Mittwoch werdet ihr ausgebildet zum Legionären Test. Und am Donnerstag habt ihr einen Gehaltscheck in der Hand und ihr seid mitten im Leben. Ihr seid da, ihr seid angekommen, ihr habt ein Kind, ihr habt eine Hypothek, ihr habt ein Auto, das kaputt ist, ihr habt eine quengelnde Frau und ihr müsst die Kinder zum Kindergarten fahren am nächsten Tag. Ja, ich bin 18 Jahre alt und ich bin drin im Leben und diese fucking Legionären sind überall. Ist das nicht ein bisschen schnell, irgendwie alles gegangen bei dir? Hi, hi, alles gut. Hey, komm, du kannst das Leben. Ich bin im Hamsterrad. Du bist neunzehn. Ich bin im Hamsterrad gefangen. Trink kurz und nach dem Spielplatz. Hast du eine Ahnung, wie viele Legionellen da drin sind? Es geht, oder nicht? Es sind überall, überall, in jeder einzelnen Wohnung, in der ich bin, wird mein Teststreifen grell lila. Lila heißt es, es ist keine Legionellen drin. Holy shit, holy moly sind da viele Legionellen drin. Weißt du noch, ob du einmal zum Snackautomaten gegangen bist? Bei unserem Legionellen Tag? Ich erinnere mich, ja. Ach was, ja genau. Wir brauchen halt nur einen Tag für die Ausbildung. Deswegen zählt auf eine Art jede Minute. Ich habe einmal kurz geblinzelt und habe ein grosses Kapitel übersehen. Nee, Gelbheise sind viele Legionellen drin. Lila ist gar keine drin. Okay, ich muss ganz, ganz viel telefonieren. Ich hole die Kinder aus dem Kindergarten. Und dann macht er drei Anrufe und dann war schon wieder alles vorbei. Ja, nee, deswegen sage ich jetzt und sage das am besten auch, wenn Leute sagen, oh, ich weiß nicht, was ich soll, nochmal irgendwie ein Sabbatical oder nochmal irgendwie mich selber finden, sagt, nee, mach doch Legionellen Tester. Mach doch einen Legionellen Tester. Ich mache meinen Legionellen Tester bei der Fernuni Hagen. Fertig. Bin schon fertig. Auf der anderen Seite muss man tatsächlich, wenn man in diesen Job geht, einsehen, es wird ein Job sein, bei dem du dein Leben lang den Feind nicht besiegen wirst.
Ja, oder.
Wird nicht passieren.
Oder du machst diesen Job, machst diese strenge Ausbildung, dauert super lang.
Investierst diese viereinhalb Stunden.
Investierst die zwölf Euro Anmeldergebühr, bist Legionellentester, kriegst du vier, acht, direkt ausgezahlt, bauch die Kr Kralle, so ne, und Altersvorsorge, alles in trockenen Tüchern und dann kommt jemand um die Ecke und sagt, Achim, dieses antilegionellen Mittel, ich kipp's kurz ins Grundwasser, und jetzt sind alle weg, was? Ja, ja, es war relativ einfach. Der Streifen ist gelb. Das heißt, es gibt keine Legionelle. Ich hätte doch... Und die Aliens gucken auf die Erde und sagen, ah krass, die sind super weit. Wir sind bei Legionellen super weit. Wir haben immer noch Legionell. Wir sind vielleicht sogar Legionell. Aber in vielen Bazillen sind sie nicht so weit. Ja, ja, kann auch sein. Ich hatte neulich Streptokocken. Aus dem Nichts. Aber könnten das nicht Aliens sein? Wir denken ja immer, Aliens sind irgendwie so grüne Gummimenschen. Was ist, wenn Aliens einfach mikroskopisch klein sind, einfach schon als Bakterien hier leben und immer sagen, Hallo, hey, Menschen, wir können euch die Zeitreise beibringen und wir nur so Mampf, Mampf, Mampf, Schimmelkäse irgendwie. Tantum Werde dreien oder um Caloabo, damit es weg ist. Hey! Hi, wir können euch erklären, wie ihr Zeitreist und letztlich viel Energie habt. Und wir mit so tsch tsch tsch sprühen die einfach, desinfizieren die weg einfach. Dann, die weg einfach ihr habt recht schlechte batterien
oder bluetooth und wir haben super fun gesellschaftsspiel das so ein bisschen wie
der siedler von katan bisschen wie kanaster aber mehr mit würfeln und ne da haben uns
jetzt schon verschiedene elienrassen bewiesen dass das schon die also meisten das beste spiel kann ja sein also haben wir denn schon mal wir schauen immer ins all hinaus schauen wir doch mal auf unser butterbrot oder herrn die oze von mir aus. Aber hört auf, nach oben zu schauen, sondern vielleicht sind die ja schon da. Ich meine, wenn du jetzt so ein neues Bakterium entdeckst, du diese Stretus Kocken, dann weißt du ja auch nicht, sind die schon immer hier gewesen oder sind die irgendwann gelandet in den winzigen kleinen Raumschiffen? Weiss man nicht, weiss man ja nicht. Das war eine Krankheit oder was. Ja, es war so, ich hätte so Mandelprobleme. Du ruf doch an. Stefan, im Ernst. Ja, und dann? Ruf doch an. Was soll ich da machen? Da komme ich vorbei. Wie kommt vorbei? Da mache ich dir eine schöne Hühnerbrühe. Hühnerbrühe? Dann streichle ich dir über die Wange. Über die Wangen, wenn sie bleiben. Dann ziehe ich dir schön die Decke bis an den Hals. Dann kümmer ich. Wärmfläschchen? Ich kümmere mich doch um dich. Machst du mir ein Wärmfläschchen? Ich bringe einen Kirschkernbeutel mit, den ich schon aufgewärmt habe, habe ich mich während der Autofahrt draufgesetzt, der ist schön warm und dann kann ich dich ein bisschen wärmen. Übrigens, meine Rückenschmerzen sind komplett weg, komplett weg. Halleluja! Deine auch? Ja. Und es ist interessant, weil jetzt kann ich mir nicht mehr vorstellen, wieso ich nicht gehen konnte mit meinen lächerlichen Rückenschmerzen. Und jetzt ist der Punkt, wo man eigentlich sich präventiv darauf vorbereiten sollte und trainieren sollte, Workout, Katze, Kuh, Katze, Kuh, Kuh, Katze, Katze, Kuh. Ich sollte jetzt reintätowieren lassen, es wird wieder passieren. Es wird wieder passieren. So in die Iris reintätowieren, so kann man sich ins Auge tätowieren, dass man es immer sieht, wie so eine Caption einfach, immer. Und dann sterbe ich so einen komischen Tod und dann so die Forensiker sehen dann dieses, es wird wieder passieren. Und dann so, what? Du Herbert, ja was, ja was? Ja, schau einmal, was der Buhr da am Arm hat, es wird wieder passieren. Ja, ist das jetzt zur Botschaft, oder was meinst du? Es wird wieder passieren. Was meinst du, was das mit Deiten kennt, also ist das jetzt... Ja, du, das wäre zur Botschaft. Auch nicht. Du sag mal, Herbert, wo kommst du denn da eigentlich? Du hast gesagt, aus Regensburg, aber du klingst so anders. Nein, ich komme nicht aus Regensburg. Und dann ziehe ich eine waffe und schiesse
flotten drei meinen kopf und ich bin tot und du als forensiker musst mich analysieren und es
ist mein erster und es steht drauf ist wieder passieren passieren bossieren ja das ist mal
ein merkwürdiger krimi irgendwie ein bisschen auf mit tattoos passt bitte aber man kann sich auch innerlich tätowieren, oder? Also du kannst dir jetzt wirklich sagen, angenommen, du willst irgendeine Botschaft hinterlassen, du hast dein Erbe in einem Schatz versteckt, kann man dann einen Tätowierer sagen, ich würde gerne meine Leber tätowieren lassen, dass die wirklich erst zum Vorschein kommt, wenn ich tot bin. Würden das ein Tätowierer machen? Die Leber tätowieren. Zu einer langen Nadel die Leber tätowieren. Und das tut nicht weh? Ich glaube, die Leber hat keinen Schmerz. Die Leber kennt keinen Schmerz. Ich habe nur nicht gehört, dass man das Gehirn geblendet aus, dass wir spüren, dass unsere Organe sich die ganze Zeit im Körper bewegen. Das habe ich nur nicht gehört. Chef, die Leber ist zwei Zentimeter nach links, einmal die Leber ist ein Zentimeter nach oben, Chef, die Leber geht jetzt ein Meter nach links, so, wir bleiben mute. Wo ist die Mute-Taste? Ganz kurz einmal, Angelika, wo ist die Mute-Taste? Weil ich will diese ganze Leitung einfach muten. Wieso wollen das alles muten? Sie kriegen nicht damit, was im Körper passiert? Ich will nicht wissen, wo die Leber genau ist, ob die jetzt ein Zentimeter da oben oder da unten. Sie wollen Leber ababonnieren. Wer sind Sie? Deabonnieren? Sie sind so skeptisch. Ich will Sie auch ausblenden. Marco, wir können nicht alle abonnieren, deabonnieren. Marco? Du musst ganz unten, ganz nach unten scrollen und dann auf Deabonnieren klicken. Und dann musst du aber einen Grund angeben. Ach, jetzt hängt der wieder. Jetzt hängt der wieder hier. Wo kann ich den Grund angeben? Ganz unten. Du musst auf Deabonnieren. Nein, nein, nein, okay, du musst hier Rechtsklick, Rechtsklick. Ach, Rechtsklick. Das ist Rechtsklick. Nicht Doppelklick, nur einmal Rechtsklick, nicht zweimal Rechtsklick. Ich weiß nicht, warum man nur einmal, warum man zweimal drücken muss. Das ist verwirrt, ja, genau. Man muss sich einmal klicken. Genau, einmal Rechtsklick, ja, und dann Speichern unter, und dann kannst du dir das als PDF auf dem Schreibtisch da musst du es dann unten unterschreiben. Passwort, weiss ich nicht mehr, was es ist. Weiss ich nicht mehr, was es ist? Ja, das weiss ich auch nicht. Wie? Warum baust du denn Passwort, um eine Datei zu speichern? Was hast du denn da eingestellt? Was kommt man denn mit dem Adobe? Was hast du denn da eingestellt? Das sollte ja überhaupt nicht sein. Passwortsteuerung. Hast du dein Schreibtisch Passwort geschützt oder was?
Ich muss ein Passwort eingeben, was könnte das sein?
Das ist aber, wenn ich meiner Mutter helfe bei solchen Problemen.
Ich bin immer optimistisch.
Aber so ein Rätsel, also ob man das jetzt lösen muss.
Was könnte das sein? Lass uns mal nachdenken.
Was könnte die Lösung sein? Was könnte das sein? Lass uns mal nachdenken. Was könnte die Lösung sein? Was könnte das jetzt sein? Und der ITler der Konversation ist so, wir können jetzt aufhören, ist ein grösseres Problem. und der reichte vielleicht so ein passwort mein sohn heisst stefan
ssw ort das nicht. Schwertfisch? Schwertfisch? Oh. Weil ich hätte... Dann nochmal ganz zurück. Wirst du nochmal? Schwertfisch. Ach. Ganz grossschreiben oder klein. Macht das einen Unterschied? Probier mal klein. Ist das mit Bindestrich? Ah, ja, klar. Ah, schwer, plötzlich, okay, ja, gut, da war alles. Okay, PDF habe ich, okay. Genau, und dann musst du unten da einen Grund angeben und dann einmal die PDF ausdrucken. Festplatte voll. Warum ist denn die Festplatte voll, da musst du erst was löschen. Festplatte voll? Warum ist die Festplatte voll?
Du hast dir die ganzen Newsletter alle da rumliegen.
Alle auf dem Desktop gezogen.
Warum?
Die ganzen Leber, Leber eins, Leber zwölf Uhr fünf, Leber zwölf Uhr sechs, du hast neunzehn Gigabyte nur von der Leber.
Ich will nicht wissen, wo die ist, ob die oben runterrutscht, ob der Darm hinter der Milz ist. Die Milz generell, mute.
Du hast 18 Notificationen von der Milz. Ah ja. So, deabonieren. Deabonieren, zack. Genau, hier, alles klar. So, abgeschickt. Gut. Jetzt hörst du nie wieder was von der Leber. Die Leber wird einfach geghostet. Die Leber wird geghostet vom Gehirn. Wer weiss, was die alles zu sagen haben. Alle Organe werden geghosted vom Gehirn. Die Positionen der Organe werden jeweils geghosted vom Gehirn. Aber man könnte, also angenommen, man könnte jetzt sich einen Chip implantieren lassen in den Kopf, der diese Zensur wieder aufhebt, könnte man rein theoretisch das wieder aktivieren. Schmerz. Man könnte wieder aktivieren, dass man wieder spürt, was die Organe alle machen. Wo sie gerade sind. Nicht, was sie machen, glaube ich. Okay, es ist nur so eine Überwachung. Wo die gerade im Körper, also diese ganzen Menschen. Machen die denn so viel, sind die so viel unterwegs? Ich glaube schon, nicht zesshaft. Ich glaube, wenn du dich oft, wenn du auf dem Rücken liegst nachts und du drehst dich auf die andere Seite, dass alle Organe, weil die Hände nur. Jumals wie beim Lotto, die ganzen Kugeln in der Lotto-Trommel, die einmal so durchgemischt werden. So sind die Organe auch bei dir. Macht es für das Herz einen Unterschied, ob man rechts oder links liegt, weil ... Du, das Herz kann auch ins Homeoffice, das ist egal. Das Herz kann arbeiten, von wo es will. Ich meine, wenn du auf rechts dich drehst, fließt dein Herz leer. Pass da draußen auf, okay? Dreht euch lieber auf links, weil sonst fließt euer Herz leer.
Ich musste letztens so lachen,
weil du hast ja mal, du meintest ja, du findest es so lustig, die Idee, dass wenn man
ich muss da immer wieder dran denken, wenn man nachts
einfach laut anfängt zu reden. Ja.
Und ich habe überlegt, weil ich habe ja schon mal tatsächlich
in einer Live-Podcast-Folge gezeigt, ich habe ja die
Scherentechnik entwickelt. Wenn du auf der Seite
legst, dann öffnest du deine Beine
Oh mein Gott! Dann öffnest du deine Beine, oh mein Gott, dann öffnest du deine Beine so, dann öffnest du deine Beine so, als würdest du rennen, ne, also du liegst auf der Seite und du öffnest die Beine so, dadurch hast du einen grossen Hebel und kannst dich einfach umdrehen. Und was ich letztens gemacht habe, ich habe mich einfach wahnsinnig schnell umgedreht. Und die Forschung fand ich auch so lustig, dass du einfach im Bett liegst, Gute Nacht, Gute Nacht, Gute Nacht und Wamm! Einfach schlagartig auf die andere. Mach das mal, es ist, es macht grossen Spaß, mach die Beine so auf und dann habt ihr wirklich einen grossen Hebel und man kann sich wirklich schlagartig umdrehen und macht das einfach mal weil mein ziel ist es dass wenn ich mich immer nur so umdrehe dass mein körper das irgendwann lernt und ich auch während dem schlaf nur noch so und man blinzelt kurz und dann liegst du schon anders weil es so schnell geht Genau, ja. Aber ich finde das faszinierend, aber auch wirklich mit dem Blut, wo es dann hinfließt, die ganzen Organe und so. Aber wahrscheinlich, also ich drehe mich sehr schlecht um, das weiss ich auch, sehr, sehr schlecht. Ja. Brauch sehr lang. Und was ich gerade dachte, Wasserbett. Ja, ist eine Gefahr. Wenn du es mit Wasserbett machst, glaube ich, ist es sehr unangenehm. Das kann, da hast du grossen Wellen, Wellengang, ja. Und bitte pass ein bisschen auf, dass du nicht so viele Wellen schlägst. Ah, okay, ich gebe mir Mühe, ja. Gute Nacht. Ahoy. Wamm! Tsunami. Genau, man hat noch so eine Sekunde Zeit und die Weile schon aussteht. Trampolin-Effekt. Aber Wasserbett sind schon geil. Wir haben einmal einen guten Arbeitssketsch gedreht, in irgendeiner Location, in irgendeiner Wohnung oder so. Manchmal werden so Wohnungen bereitgestellt einfach, dass man da drehen kann. Und dann hat man halt Zugang zur ganzen Wohnung und dann breitet man sich da aus und dreht dann irgendwie eine Küche oder so. Aber hat dann Aufenthaltsraum, Schlafzimmerimmer oder so. Und da stand halt einfach so völlig selbstverständlich ein Wasserbett. Und es war mein erster Kontakt mit dem Wasserbett tatsächlich und ich hatte so viel Spaß, in diesem Wasserbett einfach da so richtig so rumzugluckern die ganze Zeit. Und das ist richtig gut, weil es hat immer diese Verzögerung, du schickst eine Welle nach links. Um drei Uhr nachts kommt dann die Welle zurück. Wo ich mir wirklich denke, ich könnte darin nicht schlafen, weil ich die ganze Nacht einfach nur rumspiele. Und die Gezeiten. Und die Gezeiten, ja klar. Ebbe und Flut ist natürlich ein Thema. Ach, ey. Ich habe so schlecht geschlafen die Nacht, sorry, ey. Warum, was ist denn los, was ist denn passiert? Ich weiß, wir haben diese Präsentation gleich, aber ich habe so schlecht geschlafen. Ach, verdammt. Ja, es ist Vollmond ja gerade. Okay. Und ich habe das Gefühl, ich schlafe irgendwie schlecht bei Vollmond wegen Ebbe. Moment, du hast ein Wasserbett oder was? Ja, ich habe ein Wasserbett, genau. Und dann ist da ganz wenig Wasser drin bei Erd oder was? Ja, ich schlafe wie auf einem harten Untergrund. Ich schlafe wie auf so einem Gefängnissteinklotz. Das ganze Wasser ist woanders. Und wo ist das Wasser? Auf der anderen Erdseite oder? Nee, im Wasserbett. Im anderen Wasserbett.
Es gibt immer zwei.
Ja, irgendwo in Australien
ist ein Wasserbett, das gerade ganz prall ist.
Das ist zu prall.
Und wo der Australier einfach so
krumm Hohlrücken da rumliegt.
Wie so ein Seestern.
Es ist so auf so einem Stein geschnallt.
Glaubst du, dass mit diesem ...
Es gibt eine Person, die kennen wir beide. Du findest sie richtig gut, ich mag die gar nicht. Ich glaube, du weisst, wen ich meine. Nein. Und der meinte mal so zu mir so, boah, ich habe gestern echt schlecht geschlafen wegen Vollmond. Ah ja. Und dann dachte ich so, hä, das ist so ein ganz technischer Informatikmensch, Technik und so. Und dann kam der plötzlich mit so einem Vollmond-Ding. Scheiss. Und dann denke ich mir so, hä? Und dann dachte ich mir, im Ernst jetzt? Meinst du das im Ernst? Und ich als Gag, jaja. Und das ist so, manchmal haben so kleine Esoterik-Pünktchen, so kleine Kleckser im Alltag, wo man sich so denkt. Aber auf der anderen Seite, vielleicht mit der Helligkeit ist da was dran. Und letztens habe ich tatsächlich schlecht geschlafen und dann lag ich am nächsten Tag wieder im Bett und dachte mir, boah, schlaf nicht wieder schlecht, du Depp, du fetter Trottel und dann habe ich aber, ähm, die Selbsthastschiebe abends, ja, da habe ich aus dem Fenster geschaut und dann war Vollmond und dann dachte ich, womit mal, gestern war auch schon Vollmond, habe ich wirklich, obwohl ich Vorhänge habe, Anti-Mond-Vorhänge, habe ich vielleicht tatsächlich schlecht geschlafen wegen Vollmond. Ist da was dran? Ja. Hast du Anti-Vollmond-Vorhänge? Ich habe extra bei Ikea gefragt, geht der Vollmond da durch? Da haben die gesagt, äh, äh, äh, nee. Da habe ich gesagt, okay, gut, glaube ich. Wäre mir ganz besonders, so reden die ja bei Ikea. Ja, genau. Entschuldigung, haben Sie auch Vorhänge, wo der Mond nicht durchgeht?
Ja, wir haben ein paar Exemplare hier drüben.
Wir wollten ihn terküsen, aber haben uns gefragt, ob da der Mond durchgeht.
Der Mond geht da nicht durch.
Ja gut, dann nehmen wir den.
Komm, wir nehmen den.
Ja, komm. Komm jetzt. Komm, da sind wir diese Fleischsperrchen essen jetzt, die gibt es auch beim Hotdog-Stand für billiger. Aber man muss, also ja, diese Helligkeitssache, die mal ausgeschlossen, ist das wirklich einfach ein ganz grober Quatsch, wo ich dann immer interessiert bin, was sind die Esoterikpunkte dieser Person noch?
Also man will so ein Esoterikgramm erstellen. Genau, wenn jemand so etwas sagt, würde ich gerne fragen, okay, aber wir waren schon auf dem Mond. Genau, du hast dann so eine Checkliste vor dir und du sagst mir jetzt, ich habe gestern schlecht geschlafen, weil es war Vollmond. Dann sage ich, ah, okay, alles klar. Obwohl ich meine, genau, kurz hier ein paar Follow-up-Questions.
Okay.
Globuli, also so Homöopathie und so. Wirken die, ja oder nein, das ist für unsinn. Nur der Placebo-Effekt, ansonsten medizinisch kein nachgewiesener Wirkungseffekt. Okay, das also nicht. Wir waren auf dem Mond. Wir waren auf dem Mond, ja genau, Buzz Aldrin und Lance Armstrong. Die Erde, vor allem in diesem Satz, die Erde ist eine geometrische Form, also die Erde ist eine Kugel. Ja, cool. Kugel, ja. Okay, alles klar. Sternzeichen spielen eine grosse Rolle für dich? Eine sehr grosse Rolle in unserem Leben, ja. Ich bin vage und deswegen auch sehr ausgewogen und du bist Löwe? Ja, genau, das dachte ich mir schon fast. Ja, Löwen glauben oft nicht an Sternzeichen. Löwen glauben oft nicht an sich selbst. Alles klar. Reptiloide sind ein großes Problem. Mein Onkel ist Reptiloide. Nachgewiesenerweise? Oder was war es gerade?
Und dann kommt es raus, dass Repsyloiden
ganz stark an Sternzeichen glauben
und jeweils bei, gibt es vielleicht Tiere,
die bei Vollmond nicht gut schlafen?
Oh, das kann sein, kann ja natürlich auch sein,
weil ich dachte mir dann, okay, ist nicht vielleicht dieser
Werwolf-Mythos, dass es so ein paar
Leute gibt, die nachts immer nicht schlafen können
und die dann irgendwie ganz müde sind und dann entsteht daraus, ah, das sind bestimmt Wölfe. Menschliche Wolfsmonster nachts so. Das ist dann so ein Grundstein. Das ist ein bisschen durchgedreht. Jeder kennt diesen einen Kumpel, der dann die Storys ein bisschen zu übertrieben wiedergibt. Ja, ja, genau. Wo kam das Monster her? Ja. naja, gut, wo man sich ja auch sagt, okay, nee, keine Ahnung, so in Transylvanien gibt's ja diese geheimnisvollen Schlösser auf Bergen, wo niemand genau wusste, was da drin ist. Wo man dachte, okay, vielleicht gab's dann schon Volkssagen von Leuten, die halt dann da drin wohnen, der Graf, der dann halt Blut saugt und sich in eine Fledermaus verwandeln kann. Tschö. Wir haben die Tür aufgelassen, also ich weiß nicht, warum wir uns beschweren. Warum hast du die Tür aufgelassen? Ich habe mich nicht aufgelassen im Sinne von ich wollte frische Luft reinlassen, sondern ich bin irgendwie aufgegangen. Die Tür ist von alleine aufgegangen. Und du willst mir nochmal sagen, es gibt keine Geister. Du glaubst immer noch nicht an Geister. Was muss passieren, dass du an Geister glaubst? Darüber hinaus, dass einfach so die Tür aufgeht. Wer dreht Ventilatoren?
Ich habe neulich im Hotel geschlafen eine Nacht und es ging mitten in der Nacht das grosse Licht an, das grosse Deckenlicht, weil jeder weiss, wenn man ins Hotelzimmer geht, es gibt eine Milliarde Lichtschalter und du machst alle irgendwie an und alles hell und nachts, ausserdem Nichts ging das ganze Licht an. Und wie alle Menschen in Horrorfilmen reagieren, ist ja, wie man als normaler Mensch reagiert ist. und dann waren neben dem Bett so 50 Lichtschalter. Ich habe irgendeinen Render gedrückt und es war der richtige.
Es ging aus und ich habe mich gefreut, dass es der richtige.
Meine Reaktion war also so. Ach so, okay. Ah, okay, cool. Oh, hingegen der Poltergeist. Mann, Job ist nicht mehr das, was es ist. Warum bin ich hier genau in diesem Einwohnzimmer, wo genau immer nur die leute sind die nicht an poltergeister
glauben was lustig weil in horrorfilmen reagieren menschen nicht wie man wie sie normalerweise reagieren müssten sondern man sie reagieren wie der drehbuchautor oder regisseur es will richtig wie die geschichte es braucht ja sie verlassen nicht das verfluchte haus weil die stimmung wäre mega weird wenn man einfach so reagiert ja stattdessen genau was ist, was ist das für ein Horrorfilm? Das gesehen gerade? Weil auch bei Sixth Sense, dem Film Sixth Sense.
Sechs Cent.
Sagt Sechst Cent, wo es darum geht, wie weit man kommt mit Sechst Cent und kriegt man irgendwie.
Genau, ja.
Und wir wollen aber nach Amerika zurück.
Interessanter Blick auf unsere kapitalistische Gesellschaft, also ganz, ganz fantastischer.
Nicht zu Recht, mit dem sechsten Sinn.
Richtig. Wo der kleine Junge sagt zu Bruce Willis I can see them every time. Ich kann tote Menschen sehen. I can see that, guys. Und Bruce Willis sagt, what? Wohingegen die normale Reaktion wäre ja, also Menschen verschwinden ja nicht, wenn sie sterben. Ja. Ist gut bei dir? Aber der Film will... Achass es mich nochmal anders ausdrücken. Der Film will das als geiles Zitat haben, deswegen reagiert Bruce Willis sofort geschockt und sagt, du kannst Tote Menschen sehen? Aber die natürliche Reaktion, wenn irgendeinem Menschen, der diesen Film nicht kennt, ich kann Tote Menschen sehen, und diese Person würde sagen, ja, ich auch, also Leichen, du meinst Leichen, nimmst du das Wort für. Jeden Tag, ja, klar. Genau, ich bin vorhin, also ich
kenne Leichen, nur ich stand auf einem
Es wird wieder passieren.
Ne, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist, ähm,
ich sehe,
Menschen nach ihrem Ableben
in, Leichen,
Totenstarre, als, ja,
boah, lass mich nicht,
lass mich, ich versuche es irgendwie schmissig auszudrücken, verstehst du? Ja. Wir sind nicht in einem Film. Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal. Ich kann die lebenden Toten sehen. Zombies, wie ein Zombiefilm. Du meinst Zombies. Du kannst Leute nicht mehr beeindrucken. Ja. Ich kann die, ist egal. Ich kann Menschen post mortem lebendig sehen. Ich kann nach ihrem Ableben als lebendes Lebensform sehen. Und dann denkt er kurz nach. Was? Postem ja hatte ich doch gesagt posthum posthum wandelnd posthum her wandelnd also wenn er tot ist ist postmortem aber nachdem er eingegraben wurde ist posthum oder was? Humus. Humus? Genau, ja. Hum? Genau, vielleicht postthof. Also man kann post mortem, humus humus genau ja genau für die postorf also man kann post mortem
prä hum sein wenn man tot aber noch nicht eingegraben ist völlig richtig aber wenn man
sagt das buch wurde post hum veröffentlicht sagt man nicht post mortem man möchte explizit
noch mal darauf hinweisen dass derjenige im bettben ist, in der Erde mal weg in die Erde, ins All geschossen wurde. Oder Alge. Warum schießen wir unseren ganzen Müll nicht ins All? Naja, ich glaube, wir wissen warum. Weil er als Diamantregen zurückkommt. Das wissen wir wirklich. Wir können nicht den ganzen Müll, wir schmeißen ihn ja gerade, ich war neulich sehr oft auf so Wertstoffhöfen, wo man einfach Dinge wegwirft. Ja, aber Stefan, dir ist schon klar, dass der Orbit der Erde immer wieder an der gleichen Stelle ankommt. Nee, ich nehme nicht in Orbit. Also du schmeißt es raus und dann dauert es ein Jahr und dann sind wir wieder da. Und dann fliegt wieder uns die Plastiktüte ins Gesicht. Nein, ich meine nicht, ich meine weiter. Also du denk es nicht zu Ende. Ich denk viel weit zu Ende. Einfach weiterschießen. Richtung, sagen wir mal, was ist da dieser Kometengürtel? Du meinst mit einer großen Steinschleuder. Perseiden, Perseiden. Einfach weg, weg mit dem Müll. Warum schieb man dies weiter? Ja, also man hat sich ja als Menschheit gedacht, wir konzentrieren Müll. Müllhalde, Müllinsel. Warum nicht den anderen Weg? Warum nicht den gesamten Müll in eine riesige Steinschleuder packen, die das alles gleichmäßig verteilt? Im zweiten Mond. So dass es nirgendwo Müllhalden gibt, sondern der gesamte Müll gleichmäßig verteilt ist. Ja, Dann steht da überall wenig.
Ist überall wenig. Und nirgend
viel. Und nirgend viel.
Und mal
einen zweiten Mond mit Müll, Müllmond.
In weiteren Kreisen.
Dann viel Spaß mit deinem Wasserbett. Wir können auch nicht mehr schlafen.
Die ganze Zeit
vier Müllmonde ziehen
die ganze Zeit dein Wasserbett.
Morgen zum Büro, Haare zertraus.
Durch die nächste Nacht?
Nee, die Müllmonde.
Ja, das ist ein sehr,ro, Haare zersaus. Durch zächte Nacht? Nee, die Müllmonde. Die Müllmonde. Ich glaube, das kriegst du einfach bei der Partei der Wasserbettbesitzer nicht durch. Die drehen durch. Das klingt wie ein Satz aus Dune. Die Müllmonde. Die Müllmonde. Die Müllmonde von Peter Goetze. Ja, er kann auch bald der zweite Teil raussehen, den werde ich mir reinglotzen im Kino. Ich lieb den, jetzt schon.
Bester Film ever!
Der wird schon, 4 Sterne bei der Box!
Super Film, 10 von 10 Stern, 10 von 10 von 10.
Ich freue mich sehr auf den zwei.
Wir können jetzt gemeinsam in die Flimmerkiste gehen.
Und direkt danach eine Folge aufnehmen.
Und die nennen wir?
Review Dune 2.
Review Dune.
Die Müllmonde.
Ja, finde ich gut. Dann braucht ihr sehr weit, nicht ins Kino zu gehen und spart euch Geld. Ja, mehr Finanztipps gibt es nächste Woche. Ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei dir, Florentin Will. Ich steige ein, bitte schnall dich an. Okay. Letzte Woche hast du dich nicht angeschnallt, ich hatte Angst um dich beim Abheben. Ich drehe mich kurz um nochmal auf der Treppe, zum Ufu, winke kurz euch. Tschüss. Und gehe jetzt langsam, ganz belächtchtig, und halt mich gut am Geländer fest und gehe hoch, dass ihr denkt, geht's ihm gut?
Er geht viel zu langsam für seinen Alter. Geht langsam hoch. Dann mach ich mir schon mal die Tür zu und die geht hoch.
Und schnauhe euch an.
Ready for takeoff.
It's the worst bird production.